Our third question, student Redmars asks,
"Why did we choose Python?"
>>So, there are lots of languages we could have chosen--
The real reason for choosing Python is--
it is a very simple language, but it is also a language that is widely used,
and can very quickly get you on the path to building interesting programs.
There are many, many programming languages.
It is definitely important, and a great thing as you develop as a computer scientist
that you learn more and more languages.
But, to start with a language that will be easy to learn, and still powerful--
Python is a great choice for that.
There are certainly some other choices,
but I happen to think Python is a good one for this class.